hello I'm probably andrew heaton and
you're eagerly watching mostly weekly
the post-office the answer to the
burning question how can we make email
slower more expensive and stressful
nobody likes the post office including
and especially the people who work there
at this point the Postal Service is
basically a costly way to deliver junk
mail the mail is getting slower while
email Facebook and sexting keep
increasing in speed and efficiency
making the post office less and less
relevant it's time to update the Postal
Service and the best way to do it
privatizing goodbye letter your private
now why should we well for one thing
it's hemorrhaging money last year it ran
a deficit of nearly six billion dollars
and it's been running at a loss for 10
solid years since 2007 the post office
has lost over fifty billion dollars
that's over a hundred and thirty three
billion Kathryn manga award
commemorative stamps the reason it can
operate with deficits that large is
because the federal government provides
a huge line of credit to keep it afloat
which it desperately needs because the
Postal Service has seventy billion
dollars worth of unfunded liabilities
for its retirees and you know who will
wind up covering that expense
[Music]
the Postal Service's half government
agency and half corporation combining
all of the efficiency of a government
agency with the cuddliness of a large
corporation and even though it loses
billions of dollars every year it can't
go out of business because it's not
really a business what it really is is a
monopoly
it is literally illegal for anyone
except the Postal Service to deliver
letters the exception is extremely
urgent letters which is the only reason
companies like FedEx and UPS are allowed
to exist at all if not for the
post-office monopoly they could deliver
non urgent letters like birthday cards
ransom notes in packets of sea monkeys
just like the Postal Service does
incidentally catalogs and junk mail are
most of what the postal service delivers
not letters less than 5% of mail is
personal correspondence half of all mail
is just advertisements nobody wants that
makes the Postal Service a seventy
billion dollar spam folder the only
really important thing the Postal
Service still takes care of is bills but
I have a feeling people I owe money to
will still figure out how to get those
bills to me with or without stamps damn
it the post office uses revenues from
its monopoly mail services to subsidize
their Express and package delivery
services because they lose money on
those services why competition does
better for example I can get a package
and then order it on Amazon Instant
which but whenever the Postal Service
tries to find ways to save money like by
scrapping Saturday mail delivery or
shutting down inefficient rural offices
or automating their 535 micromanagers in
Congress freaked out in order of them
not to
there are 31,000 post offices in America
that's more than all Starbucks and
McDonald's combined and most of them
lose money maybe that's why they lost
5.6 billion dollars last year that's why
I say privatize the Postal Service
make the Postal Service compete but also
give it the freedom to be innovative
without some crusty senator ordering it
around other countries have already
privatized their postal services in one
form or another the United Kingdom
Sweden the Netherlands Germany Japan in
that place with hobbits now we use email
instantaneously and cheaply we don't
send letters we use Facebook or whatsapp
or Grindr
I mean tinder I meant everyone heard me
say tender it was tender the fact of the
matter is times have changed and keep
changing it's time for the post office
to catch up and modernize if you love
something privatize it go on let her get
out of here I never liked you anyway
go on get better off without me no
matter how painful if it comes back
that's beautiful
if it goes out of business well maybe it
was never meant to be
[Applause]
[Music]